et sachez que le nouveau dispositif de
chômage partiel sera en vigueur jusqu'en
2022 annonce de la ministre du travail
ce matin chez nos confrères de france
info
rlp nico indiquent des contreparties
seront exigés et conditions de la
prolongation doivent être définies en
les prochains jours un soulagement pour
certains commerçants commencer par les
hôteliers pour aujourd'hui pour
l'hôtellerie restauration pour survivre
à ces crises donc c'est quelque chose
qui est une grande chance quand même
pour l'hôtellerie restauration et nous
aurons besoin de cette aide le plus
longtemps possible parce que la
répercussion de ces crises n'est pas sur
deux ou trois mois
on estime aujourd'hui qu'elle ait au
moins sur un an et demi par exemple on
estime que la perte du chiffre
d'affaires sur l'année 2020 sera de 50%
pour l'hôtellerie restauration et on n'a
aucune visibilité encore sur 2021 il va
y avoir un impact de toute façon on va
avoir des fermetures
sait on est certain qu'il y aura des
fermetures d'ici très peu de temps le
mois de septembre
donc des z on aura besoin d'un maximum
d'être on n'est pas encore sûr de
comment sera la reprise la confiance des
clients la confiance des clients
internationaux aussi sur la france et
surtout si on a une deuxième vague
qu'est ce qui va se passer donc
aujourd'hui on est dans une grosse
incertitude
malheureusement je pense que malgré tous
les efforts que peut faire le
gouvernement
on n'en sortira pas indemne